sup everyone it's one and it's the live
premiere of the Wonder Woman 1984
official trailers gal gadot is talking
right now they're about to show it at CC
XP there it is Wonder Woman 1984
official trailer live at CCX beef there
we go
[Applause]
I love Kristen Wiig she's awesome
[Music]
stranger things but it's for sure let's
go
today
back
somehow
Cheeta
Spira oh snap
[Music]
swinging off the light yes Golden Eagle
over Oh so awesome she's gonna
breakdance oh there it is the official
trailer for a Wonder Woman 1984 that was
really awesome I can't believe we saw
the golden eagle armor in the trailer
for the very first time I thought that
we would definitely have to wait to see
it in the movie so that was insanely
awesome Wonder Woman the first one or
one of the movie probably my favorite DC
movie I really really love that movie
it's hard to say but it's right up there
and Wonder Woman is one of my favorite
superheroes so I'm super excited for
this let me know how excited you are for
it in the comments down below let me
know what you thought about the official
premiere for the Wonder Woman 1984
trailer so always think you all so much
for watching
woof woof